jean-paul vous êtes ici pour nos jours
heureux des risques les anneaux et
olivier nakache avec marilou berry omar
omar sy d omar et fred un de frais d
omar dix ans jacques boudet jean
benguigui joséphine de meaux sortie le
28 juin par le pitch une joueuse raconte
les aventures tragi-comiques de vincent
vous donc responsable d'une colonie de
vacances
pris en sandwich entre un staff
déboussolé déjanté et des mômes
ingérable alors il ya le frein pour y
aller il ya les veillées autour du feu
il ya des courses en sac
il ya les premiers flirts enfin il ya
tout quoi c'est la colo quoi ré c'est
très émouvant même temps ouais bah c'est
très émouvant je suis d'accord ça plaira
voulzy je pense ça tu vas télé en colo
dans des petits ah bah oui bah oui tu
vas voir tu l'adoré mais en fait dès
l'es2 real nakache et toledano ils sont
beaucoup à légende colo voilà et c'est
en fait leurs souvenirs qu'on retrouve
dans le film ans une bonne comédie
populaire avec nous mais ça m'a plu et
des rires des larmes de la musique
derrière tu as fait une allusion au film
est drôle
les bengals enter pour le bisou pour
s'embrasser comme celle ci avec marcela
taylor sa machine on ne marche pas tout
le temps le match panne tout le temps ce
coup là et essaye avec nadine faisait
une pause bisous médine
ça dépendra tout le monde l'a dit et
après on fume un pet
quand on l'a dit nadine alari votre
situation personnelle s'est mariée mère
de famille je suis député c'est ça ma
situation paris mais n'y a pas que ça
dans la vie
elle une grande enseigne à rallier une
grande maison avec ses parents les
chiens trois enfants tous savent à quoi
ça va vous le dit lui même
alors vous m'avez pas posé la même
question si vous vous et non on est bien
content que nadine et l'ump sont pas
dans le film
la sortie aux entrées de mercredi soir
des dégâts n'est jamais allé en colo
mais on a l'impression que tu as fait ça
toute sa vie d'acteur c'est ça j'étais
monsieur batignole jamais été collabo
non plus donc c'est vrai qu'on entend
voilà c'est ça